[Music]
slap car in the driveway next door
the neighbors move in
[Music]
hey it's got Maravich like Prentiss
Jenna come over me Mike our new neighbor
hi hi I'm Jenna
how long have you been married just four
months actually they seem nice enough
good-looking couple - they're just young
that's 10 years younger
uh-huh come on I've never had a piece of
strange instrument married to Lisa hey
never you think maybe you could give me
some pointers whenever you're ready
[Music]
I heard the fight that God had the other
day he has to watch his temper what has
been drinking so what were you doing in
my house I heard it's great okay dad
about let me give you a hand and he's
the one that wanted to get married he
wants to have kids
well you I don't even know if leaving is
the right thing you know whatever you
decide I understand she's pretty isn't
she
and yeah hey hon Mike how's it going
it's just something about Scott it's not
a good guy
[Music]
everything's gonna be okay
you